tokyo game show is on right now in Tokyo
Mary Kish is there Justin hey Walters
there alexa ray Korea's technically
doesn't start until Thursday oh really
yeah this is pre tokyo game show preteen
yes pre TGS is on right now kids and I
got Peter Brown I'm like my hearty here
to tell us all about all about Sonia
news yeah you were here late last night
is that correct yep look at Sony news
yeah I got in 40 GS in the state for
destiny nice yeah we were running on
fumes right now it's been like 12 hours
I got some sleep oh you did more than
Taye correct but yeah took her game
shows a lot sony just kind of came out
and just showed trailer after trailer
after trailer without much talking yes I
here and they would walk people as was
it she I came out and then said here's a
trailer for this and then the trailer
played and then he came and said here's
the trailer for this but was weird is it
every time he came out said something he
dropped the mic every time like dropping
the mic it loses its imp no but did you
imagine if every time he said something
he did that people be like all right we
get it I would stay up to watch it but I
didn't but I watched the news on
gamespot com today and the first thing I
saw was that they're okay the first
thing I saw which I cared about was that
they're making really sexy colored
PlayStation for us Peter you have some
really nice called a PlayStation tues
and stuff locked away in your house are
you excited that collared ps4s yeah no
really it's not really good colors it's
not colored ps4 is it's colored plates
it's like a knack or white ps4 look look
it looks like an apple commercial so it
must be good like colorful look at it
it's correct black like it's fine I mean
I'm I'm more enticed by the controllers
which maybe there's really no difference
between one offering or the other but uh
the controllers are kind of classy I'm
honest so the the faceplates this is the
HDD version of the ps4 is not a way of
title it's a weird title but do we
actually know that they're not gonna
work on the original because they'd be
alienating everyone who didn't buy ps4
until the last month cuz that version
technically just came out and it's like
slightly different in some dimensions
but is it easier to take off the the
answer because it is actually not that
hard to open what's the ps4 it sound
like different to replace a hard drive
it's it's a relatively in comparison to
ps3 it's a relatively simple procedure
history is pretty easy man it's 20 so
it's like the 20 bucks or seller or what
like I don't know
en works yeah right now it's about 20
bucks okay it's about a hundred and ten
fifteen thousand yen that sounds were
less your heart that sounds wrong and
why is this only coming in Japan yeah I
give it time it'll come back here so is
this gonna be like PlayStation TV and
our PS Vita TV or whatever they ended up
calling it this stuff just only gets
like it's Japan like a testing ground or
did they just love their own i guess
home audience so much they make sure
this stuff gets simplest they've been
doing this for years japanese companies
typically really stuff over there first
so and i look i mean i think if you look
at the market right now Japan console
sales are down so this and some of the
other things they announced our kind of
I think a good initiative to bump up
interest and maybe capture an audience
that wasn't there to begin with all
right let's talk about sexy controllers
you seem to like so it's coming out in
gold silver steel black and my favorite
look at that crystal yeah sound like
yeah what's your favorite Mike I'm in
the lot of people have been saying they
like the crystal I don't like it it
kinda reminds me those cheap mad catz
controllers don't you talk you all about
magnetics I really like the silver you
like the Civil add the black steel black
is kind of the silver one looks too much
like the white one which they already
filled yeah I can see that but maybe if
it's shiny enough gold all the time no
yeah I don't think I can call me
pretentious I don't think I got the
whole off gold like I would love to walk
around San Francisco without a chain
almost yeah and then just see what
people think and then start using it
people would think looks fine cuz jerks
right here right those dumb scooter
things you stand on the black one looks
like just a regular could I wouldn't I
need to see you side by side to see you
how different that looks but the crystal
one it's like that bound one was saying
on it's like that goofy n64 see through
one yeah that there was a bunch of that
I had like three different 1000 yeah I'd
like to show you had a bunch as well
yeah seed inside the controller you
don't like that oh no not a fire I got
maybe a large shoulder that's how much I
care about color have a red one you're
it there's a red one away 1 I don't know
that's out here yet someone got it for
me as a gift mayor in Japan Jesus that
guy well yeah I just I'm so delighted it
just friends all over the world excuse
us buy me things unbelievable I have not
seen that nice can I borrow it no cuz
you'll never see it again yeah
playstation vr that's a name that we
they probably had
50 hours worth of meetings for was just
the most basic I like to project
Morpheus I got I'd gotten used to it
yeah yeah what about what you guys think
I think it'll make sense to a broader
audience now especially when like the
main challenge of VR is trying to you
know communicate it to the general
public who might otherwise not spend the
money I don't know that just [ __ ] all
this yeah it means take the blue pill
take the red pill yeah jacking into the
matrix that sort of main means the
PlayStation so the Trinity PlayStation
neo could have gone with any of them
they just didn't get laurence
fishburne's sign off I guess and it's
cool technology do you think when I
think about them calling at the
PlayStation VR it's like they're trying
to address that problem that you know
the wii u sort of bumped into a little
bit where they want to say it's
something different and new but it's
like it's associated with the
playstation it's not just like this
wholly separate thing it's almost like
the inverted problem that the wii u out
and one of the quotes we have here is
the name PlayStation VR not only
directly expresses an entirely new
experience from PlayStation that allows
players to feel as if they are
physically inside a virtual world of the
game so that's Duffy how entirely new
entirely new feels like a stretch
considering your need a ps4 and
presumably move controllers to get this
thing to work they haven't released a
release date or anything Peter you you
follow your stuff quite a lot you're
very much like early on terms of oculus
and things like that how far away do you
think playstation vr is because I feel
like every time we go to an event
there's like more and more station
showing Morpheus to people at the
accession vor to people I think we'll
start seeing it pop up in stores and
have like demo kiosks for people to give
it a try is that I'm gonna be really
smart pursuing to do that i'd say this
upcoming summer nah you know summer 2016
yeah i imagine a fall 2016 launch that's
that's my optimistic outlook if they
wait much longer than that they're gonna
run into the problem of announcing this
thing too soon so you know showing too
many of the same things too often people
want to get their hands on this stuff to
get excited about it they don't want to
watch a trailer or Schmucks like us
telling them why it's great when you can
try it and next year oculus involved are
also going to have versions of their
hardware acts as well for people to
develop is uh I think they said
uary now in november i think some devs
were getting it early in november still
q1 is still the deal for oculus you know
I mean sony has the advantage i think
and for some consumers because the
playstation brand is more recognizable
than oculus or valve yeah those are very
meet enthusiasts kind of brands so
whatchu hey on the cover of time though
jumping on a pigeon flapping I want to
see that like a brick be floppy shoe a I
am another I guess that this is sort of
more to do with the Japanese market than
ours certainly which is that there has
been a price traffic ps4 as well if you
convert it to USD and it's now at 292
dollars down from 334 sort of the sort
of piecemeal um twice caught you tend to
see after a year or two and most
consoles it's interesting if you
actually look at that price a lot of
Japanese price tags include tax right
before the price so that may even be
cheaper equivalent if you take the tax
differences into account off as well so
it's ps4 struggling a little bit in
Japan just pretty much all consoles
alright like mobile gaming is a massive
pull it for than that as well yeah
you've got games like puzzles & Dragons
dominating the gaming landscape over
there and you know Xbox is selling
hundreds of units per week which is Wow
nothing yeah the 3ds is like dominating
you know so yeah I mean I think this is
sort of like the colors introducing
those it's a good way for them to stoke
interest for new consumers but I think
it'd be strange if we didn't see
something else happen for Europe and
North America you've got Paris game week
coming up maybe Sony I'll say something
there for Europe the PlayStation
experience coming up in December for
North America you will hear something
about that there so this could be an
indication of Sony's you know moving
across the board rather than just in
Japan this is Japanese biggest gaming
event this is their time to say we you
know we still matter in the global
gaming landscape so you know gives them
a sense of pride perhaps and you know
shows that Sony cares met them yeah same
reason Microsoft always do a fifa bundle
at games come right here exactly thanks
europe thanks very much peter brown like
my hardy for coming on talking all about
tokyo game show and all the news coming
out there of course we have boots on the
ground in tokyo as well all week so make
sure you check games
calm for all the latest news and video
features for stuff that's coming out of
tokyo game show